[Music]
two sisters take the same DNA test the
results show that one sister is 10%
French the other 0% both sisters share
the same two parents and therefore the
same set of ancestors so how can one be
10% more French than the other tests
like these rely on our DNA to answer
questions about our ancestry but our DNA
actually can't tell us everything about
who we are or where we're from DNA tests
are great at answering some questions
like who your parents are but can
provide baffling results to others like
whether you have ancestors from a
particular region to understand why it
helps to know where our DNA comes from
in the first place each person's DNA
consists of about six billion base pairs
stored in 23 pairs of chromosomes 46
total that may seem like a dizzying
amount of information but 99% of our
genome is shared among all humans the
remaining 1% contains everything
distinct about an individual's ancestry
commercial DNA tests utilize less than
1% of that 1% one chromosome in each
pair comes from each parent these halves
join conception when a sperm and egg
each with only 23 chromosomes combined
the story of our ancestry becomes
muddled before conception that's because
the 23 chromosomes in a sperm or egg
aren't identical to the chromosomes of
every other cell in the body as they go
from a cell with 46 chromosomes to a sex
cell with only 23 the chromosomes within
each pair swap some sections this
process is called recombination and it
means at every sperm
egg contains single chromosomes that are
a unique mashup of each pair
recombination occurs uniquely in each
sex cell making two sisters chromosomes
different not only from their parents
but from each other's recombination
happens before conception so you get
exactly half of your DNA from each
parent but going further back things get
more complicated without recombination
you would get a quarter from each
grandparent an eighth from each great
grandparent and so on that because
recombination happens every generation
those numbers vary the more generations
removed and ancestries the more likely
they won't be represented in your DNA at
all for example without recombination
just one sixty-fourth
of your DNA would come from each
ancestor six generations back because of
recombination that number can be higher
that we don't know for sure how high or
it can be as low as zero so one sister
isn't more French in the sense of having
more ancestors from France instead the
French ancestors are simply more
represented in her DNA but the story
doesn't end there the tests don't trace
the DNA of the sisters actual French
ancestors we don't have access to the
genomes of deceased individuals from
previous generations instead these
results are based on a comparison to the
DNA of people living in France today the
tests look for genetic markers or
combinations of genetic markers these
markers are short sequences that appear
in specific places the sister deemed
more French shares genetic markers with
people currently living in France the
assumption is that these shared markers
indicate ancestor
from the same place France it's
important to note the results are based
on people who've had their genome
sequenced 80 to 90 percent of which are
of European descent many indigenous
peoples are barely represented if at all
the test won't reveal heritage from
people not represented in the database
and shouldn't be used to prove race or
ethnicity and as more people get
sequenced your results might change
looking further back you may get a
result like 2% neanderthal
though Neanderthals were a separate
species from humans that 2% doesn't come
out of the 99 percent of our genome
shared among all humans but the 1% that
varies that's because about 40,000 years
ago certain human populations interbred
with Neanderthals meaning some people
alive today have Neanderthal ancestors
many Neanderthal ancestors in fact there
are so many generations in 40,000 years
that a single Neanderthals genetic
contribution would be untraceable you
can be both a hundred percent French and
two percent Neanderthal though both come
from the one percent of DNA that makes
us different their accounting for
different things looking for traces of
our ancestry in our DNA gets complicated
very quickly both the way we inherit DNA
and the information available for
testing makes it difficult to say
certain things with a hundred percent
certainty when you think of the
discovery of DNA you probably think of
two names Watson and Crick but there is
a third unsung scientist whose name you
should know get the story of the woman
behind the double helix with this video
[Music]